el pánico de los primeros días en odessa
cuando la población empezó a oír porque
pensó que un ataque especialmente
marítimo era inminente ha dado paso a
una mayor tranquilidad de nuestras
últimas semanas o estos últimos días si
bien en aquel momento por ejemplo estas
calles se llenaron de personas que
vigilaban especialmente cuando caía la
tarde después de las seis de la tarde
había toques de queda y ellos pedían a
la población que apagara todas sus luces
o se encerrarán en sus casas con las
cortinas para que no se viera ningún
rayo de luz esto ha ido cambiando el
toque de queda se ha ido aplazando y
mayor número de gente se ve en las
calles especialmente en restaurantes y
cafés durante las horas del día ahora
que hace más calor y es primavera estas
calles hace unas horas estaban llenas de
personas y si bien muchos comercios
siguen cerrados la población que queda
se ha volcado a ayudar no solamente a
quienes defienden la ciudad sino también
a quienes llegan buscando ayuda a que
han llegado miles de desplazados no
solamente de otras provincias del país
como jarquín o también kiev sino también
llegan desde
acciones cercanas que soy hoy en día
frente de batalla como es el caso de
mico light es así como el por ejemplo
hemos visto que a pesar del ataque del
lunes el primer ataque que fue en la
línea costera que venía desde un buque
la ciudad ha ido recuperando más o menos
su normalidad y esa angustia que había
al principio ha ido mermando con los
últimos días